let's make this introduction Shaw in
this video we will showcase to you the
10 movie monsters that are bigger than
Godzilla 2019 but we are not going to
include other Toho or monster verse
kaiju
so let's check out the list number one
mega kaiju from the Pacific Rim
uprising the mega kaiju is an
amalgamation of Ryan Haku juh and Shrek
thorn mushed together by swarms of
smaller robotic hybrid guide you
it displays attributes of its previous
forms and towers over the jaegers the
mega kaiju is a hexa pedal kaiju with
two tails that have spear shaped and
similar to Shrike thorns the arm
carapace of her Kuja on his two arms and
four digitigrade legs and Shrike thorns
shoulders fused with write-ins upper arm
structure its height is 128 meters or
more than 420 feet tall and its length
is over a hundred meters or 330 feet
long however though it's slightly towers
over to it though it's slightly towers
over to 2019 Godzilla his weight is just
less than 8% of the G man number two
sand worm from dune 1984 the sand worm
was a native life-form of the planet
Arrakis he lived in the vast desert sand
sand dunes that stretch over the surface
of the planet simply put the sand worm
was an essential factor in the creation
of the spice melange sand worms left
beneath the sand
attracted to the rhythmic vibrations on
the surface they would breach in pursuit
of the origin of such vibrations this
was an effort to defend their territory
of which they were highly protective the
Sanwa was the probe dominant life-form
on Arrakis both honored and fear viral
and deadly the San Juans were extremely
territorial as soon as two worms sense
each other's presence
the allure of chuffing rose of challenge
bellowing melange smelling exhaust from
the governess Truths
my animals time as sand worms could grow
to an enormous size doctor you cited
that specimens up to 450 meters long
was spotted by observers in a deep
desert number three Chronos from wrath
of the Titans Cronus is the king of the
Titans the father of the gods crowns
current physical form is composed of
lava and molten rock lines of lava
surround Cronus's body mouth and eyes
which would suggest that the inside of
his body is completely composed of lava
he is capable of projecting massive
waves of lava from his arms it is also
seen at Kronos can spawn hordes of Makai
from his very own flesh or at least
projected from the rivers of lava or
Tartarus Kronos the fiery leaders of the
Titans and Jews his father was about 500
metres tall and the place where he was
imprisoned Tartarus itself was some five
thousand six hundred kilometers high it
was seen that when Cronus emerged into
the surface he was as big as the
mountain he came out of and the only way
that he could be defeated was with all
the Olympus gods along with the gigantic
kraken joining forces together number
four Surtur from thor ragnarok 2017
saddam was the ruler of Muspelheim
prophesized to be the one to initiate
Ragnarok sutta was successfully defeated
by Odin who stole from him the source of
his power
the eternal flame before banishing him
and his entire race to Muspelheim after
Odin went missing following the second
Dark Elf conflict a week inserter
intended to finally start Ragnarok only
to be defeated and killed by Thor
despite this loki later resurrected him
with the eternal flame and used him to
defeat heller the fire demon then
fulfilled the prophecy of Ragnarok by
destroying Asghar along with Heller and
himself in the process unaware that the
realm had already been evacuated moments
before sutter could complete his destiny
though he had grown to the size of a
mountain estimates anywhere between 500
meters to a kilometer in height however
Heller rose from below the Bifrost
bridge and fiercely attempted to battle
again concerta
using all her neck results to impale the
fire demon however sutter remained
unaffected
his final strike cost the foundations of
Asghar to implode finally destroying it
and killing himself
number five eggs Agathe from starwars
eggs goats also known as space lots of
giant space locks were members of a
silicon-based species that resided in
the hollows of asteroids at least one
such creature lived in the hot asteroid
belt space locks reach full maturity at
10 meters and reproduced by splitting
into two smaller separate bodies and if
a space slug was incapable of this
process its growth continued
uninterrupted potentially reaching
lengths of 900 meters slots of this size
were known to swallow starships whole
and house entire ecosystems after the
Battle of Hoth the Millennium Falcon
unable to jump to Lightspeed due to its
damaged hyperdrive fled pursuing Tie
Fighters by hiding inside what they
believe to be the creator of a large
asteroid in reality the MA was a giant
space lock where he also tried to repair
the Falcon's hyperdrive the space lucky
merge and snaps its jaws and a falcon
but the freighter was too fast so it
receded into the crater number 6
parallax from green lantern parallax was
created as a result of the guardian of
the universe
Crona becoming possessed and corrupted
by the yellow energy of fear he caused
great destruction until he was
imprisoned on the planet rate by the
green lantern abin sur he is
accidentally freed by alien astronauts
that came upon this prison perilous
began killing other Green Lantern's and
destroying other civilizations until it
reached earth as parallax arrived on
earth interrupting Hector and House
battle parallax kills Hector for failing
to destroy Hal and attempts to finish
the job himself but Carol Ferris helped
him escape Hal Jordan then tricks
parallax into following him out to space
where he is trapped in the Sun's
gravitational pull and burnout by the
sun's heat in his amorphous form
parallax was seen to envelop entire
cities and would have been more than two
to three kilometers or almost 2 miles
cross number seven Glover monster from
Cloverfield paradox Glover is the given
name of an underwater life form that
appears in Glover feel and Cloverfield
paradox the monster came from the
atlantic ocean where it was awakened by
that grottoes submarines sent down from
joy station to investigate the monster
rampages through Manhattan destroying
city in its path the destruction caused
the United States government to
sacrifice New York City in an attempt to
kill the monster with heavy ordnance in
the hammer down protocol the monster is
a to hunt 42 tree an 8-foot high
quadruped it with long try for fin tail
but was said to be just a baby in the
movie however in the third installment
of the club film franchise Cloverfield
paradox at the end of the movie the
clever monster was seen yet again in
this movie the monster towered above all
the clouds while it was standing in a
place that was a part of an ocean this
could have meant that the creature was
many kilometres of miles in height many
fan estimates give the Glover at five to
six kilometers tall or 3 to 4 miles in
height number eight the swimmer vemma
north from solo a Star Wars story the
swimmer Verma knots were gargantuan
spacefaring beasts with tentacles and
multiple eyes they dwelt in the a Cadiz
Maelstrom and were embedded in legends
of what travelers may encounter in the
year 10 before the Battle of Yavin han
Solo and the rest of Beckett's gang
unintentionally awoke Asuma Verma north
near the mark cluster the massive beast
began pursuing Solo who flew the
Millennium Falcon near gravity well Solo
then ejected the Falcons escape pod
which the Zoomer vermin off chase
instead right into the gravity well the
swimmer beminat was caught by the
gravity well and his skin being torn
from its skeleton before being pulled in
in the movie we could see that the
Kessel run monster or asuma vermin off
was in the range of 5 to 10 kilometers
or 3 to 6 miles across
if stretched from technical to technical
number nine ego from guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 ego was a celestial a
primordial and an extremely powerful
being as well as the biological father
of star-lord a ruthless megalomaniac
cool entity possessing a god complex eco
only decided to find some meaning and
had attempted to do so by conquering the
entire universe via an homicidal
extinction level event known as the
expansion which would terraform off
life-sustaining planets via the
implanting of alien seedlings two
extensions of himself over millions of
years
egos origin remained unknown by nature
of the ego remember himself being born
unaccompanied perilous and bodyless he
discovered the ability to manipulate
molecules and matter which led him to
construct a protective cone around
himself over the course of many years he
continued to build planetary layers over
the core which evolved into a planet
itself and the planet was dated by ego
himself as no larger than the Earth's
moon around 3,500 kilometers or 2,200
miles across although in other content
it was said to be over 6,000 kilometers
or three thousand seven and fifty miles
in diameter
number ten Galactus from Fantastic Four
Galactus was a cosmic entity born with
the universe itself he preserves the
balance of life eating planets just as a
lion does by eating antelopes
he sends his Herald Silver Surfer who
entered his service for preventing him
to destroy his planet he sends him along
to the galaxy to search for suitable
planet when the surfer finds earth
Galactus is called by his servant and he
travels the whole universe to reach him
when he arrives
anyway so the server has learned the
value of life and confronts him in space
rat phases master and releases all at
once the cosmic power Galactus gave him
thus destroying him and Galactus
Galactus was seen to fly bar Saturn and
totally ripping off its rings and in the
final scenes he was seen as a terrifying
Strom
or an amalgamation of clouds power and
debris stretching ten times the diameter
of the earth
putting him way over 100,000 kilometers
or 60,000 miles so this is the end of
the list and Galactus wins
do you like share and subscribe and tell
us your ideas for videos and we will
surely mention you in the video this is
a new thing okay so click the
notification bell again for regular and
actual notifications
[Music]